President Trump says he will not fire
special counsel Robert Muller the
president spoke out last night after his
attorney accused Muller of improperly
obtaining tens of thousands of emails
covering the time before mr. Trump took
office Paula Reid is at the Justice
Department Paula good morning a good
morning a lawyer for president Trump's
transition team claims that some of the
emails that Muller has obtained contain
privileged information and that the
transition team was not able to review
those emails before they're handed over
to Special Counsel the president last
night quashed Capitol Hill rumors that
he was poised to fire special counsel
Robert Muller what else
what are you surprised Democrats and
Republicans agree on Muller's integrity
I have confidence in director molar I do
not at all believe that that mr. molars
has been compromised or his
investigation
I think he's beyond reproach but the
president said he was troubled by
allegations made by his transition team
that Muller got unauthorized access to
thousands of transition emails quite sad
to see that my people were very upset
about it
Muller is pushing back and says the
emails were obtained legally in a rare
statement his spokesman said when we
have obtained emails we have secured
consent or appropriate criminal process
I can't imagine there's anything on him
frankly because as we said there's no
collusion there's no collusion
whatsoever but a lot of lawyers thought
that was pretty sad the Muller probe
faces increasing attacks from
Republicans over a top FBI investigator
who was dismissed from the investigation
let's get all the documents let's bring
him in for depositions now Republicans
say they will subpoena FBI
counterintelligence agent Peter struck
and senior FBI lawyer Lisa Paige who
texted criticism of then candidate
Donald Trump throughout the campaign
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders says that the White House
continues to fully cooperate with the
special counsels probe and they expect
it to wrap up soon but sources close to
the case say this investigation will go
well into next year
Gail all right Paula thank you